[Applause]
thank you for we're bucking me up
because it you know I it's so nice that
you're in a good boat because it's it's
hard to be in a good mood these days
with the news I mean I think longtime
viewers of this show know that there's
two things I really could give a [ __ ]
about royalty and babies but I'm reading
about the Royal baby it's just nice if
there's something in the news that makes
me not want to go doctor shopping for
opiates
so yes Prince Harry and Megan Marco the
Duchess of who gives a [ __ ] way early on
Monday little baby made his brexit and
you know sad I'm even talking about it
but it but he's the first royal baby
that has American blood if you don't
count Trump you know see it always gets
[Applause]
but I tell you that Megan she is a woke
princess boy oh boy kid is five days old
she said to him today my eyes are up
here
[Applause]
look at this but Danny came out just in
time for Mother's Day isn't that nice
Mother's Day you remember that Sunday
don't forget that [ __ ] rule the day we
honored the woman who fed us and raised
us and paid bribes to get us into USC
that's the only normal things that are
going on in the world right down really
even the things that kind of seem normal
or not normal like Trump nominated a
guide to be the secretary defense today
it's a Boeing executive to be the
Secretary of Defense he will oversee the
army the Navy the Air Force well one
thing he has proven he has he can kill
people with planes I know that's it's
such a terrible joke I almost couldn't
get it out but I'm so glad I did anyway
but that's not really no it's not really
normal that the president's son is
subpoenaed he was subpoenaed yesterday
Don junior they want to ask questions
about his meetings with the Russians and
Don juniors not having it
but yeah that'll change things Oh Don
jr. said again I already lied about this
and and he's not gonna go anyway I mean
the president has decided that laws
don't apply to him I mean Donald Trump
with the he'll never forget this this
could only happen with the help of the
Republican Senate
he's been asserting executive privilege
about the Mulla report forbidding
officials to testify with blowing off
subpoenas just completely saying no
cock-blocking all the attempts to see
his tax returns it turns out we're not
the resistance is the resistance it's
like it's like if in law and order it
began within our system the people are
represented by two separate groups the
Congress who writes the laws and the
executive who says go [ __ ] yourself can
we see his taxes no do we get to see the
unredacted Mullah report No are you
having entanglements and making money
from foreigners yet I mean no
[Applause]
Trump's attitude on the separation of
powers is basically talked to the hand
fat Donnie to Congress lose my number
your fake government Trump of course you
know this has not read the Constitution
he once skimmed it for his name and now
he's discovered this new thing that he
can say to break the law executive
privilege didn't know that Putin that's
his new favorite phrase executive
privilege it's even better than white
privilege the ranking Democrat Jerry
Nadler has been waiting all week and
from last week to find out when he
conceived the redacted Muller report and
he got his answer on Wednesday when pigs
fly out of Putin's ass bar wrote him a
letter he said executive privilege [ __ ]
even though this doesn't remotely apply
to this case he might have invoked the
infield fly rule it would have been the
same thing like saying teacher you can't
keep me after school I have a note from
Burger King
so Democrats voted this week to hold bar
in contempt shut up it's not doing any
good hold it miss what he's the top law
enforcement official in the country
who's going to arrest him Inspector
Gadget and then they went and we might
censor him oh great and don't forget to
put a note on his windshield it's
Chinatown Jake that's what we're living
in America's China and Democrats they
can't make any political hay out of any
this it came out this week that from
1998 II ninety eighty five to ninety for
those ten years Trump lost more money
than anybody else in America and paid no
telling Democrats you can't do anything
about that Elizabeth Warren start
calling him broke ohonta s--
[Applause]
you can't do anything with that he sold
himself to this country as a business
genius
turns out he's a reverse billionaire his
economic value was minus one point one
seven billion dollars and today Milani
he was like tell me again why I'm
[ __ ] this guy
[Applause]
you